une prolongation de la prestation
canadienne d'urgence pourrait coûter
plus de 60 milliards de dollars à la
demande d'un député conservateur le
directeur parlementaire du budget a
analysé deux scénarios concernant une
prolongation de ce programme
dans les deux cas la pcu serait
prolongée jusqu'en janvier 2021 et les
prestataires pourrait recevoir des
prestations pendant 12 semaines de plus
pour un total de 28 semaines
cette prolongation coûterait 50 7
milliards 900 millions de dollars en ce
moment une personne qui gagne plus de
1000 $ par mois ne peut pas recevoir la
prestation canadienne d'urgence
si le programme était modifié pour que
les prestations diminue graduellement 50
cents pour chaque dollar gagné au dessus
de 1000 $ le coût pourrait grimper à 64
milliards s'ajouteraient aux programmes
actuels en date de quatre joueurs
ottawa avait reçu près de huit millions
et demi de demander à verser 43
milliards 500 millions de dollars de
prestations avec nous ce soir
yves giraud directeur parlementaire du
budget bonsoir monsieur giroux bonsoir
monsieur clients est-ce qu'il est
soutenable sur le plan financier de
prolonger comme ça la pcu jusqu'en
janvier 2021 avec 28 semaines de
prestations au total au lieu de 16 comme
c'est le cas présentement c'est c'est
sûr que c'est souhaitable mais c'est
soutenable uniquement dans l'optique où
ce programme là serait prolongée mais
prolongé une fois le risque par contre
c'est que en le prolongeant on risque
d'accroître les attentes des canadiens
pour que le programme soit non seulement
prolonger encore une fois au delà de
janvier mais qu'il soit aussi rendu
permanent et c'est ça qui risque de ne
pas être viable à long terme
ton plus on met un programme qui se pose
est en parlera plus on le prolonge plus
on élève les attentes des canadiens pour
qu'ils ce programme qui est plus
généreux et plus facile d'accès que
l'assurance-emploi même plus on met les
attentes élevées pour que ce programme
l'autre deviennent permanents ou encore
que ça se répercute via des
enrichissements au programme d'assurance
emploi qui est elle risquerait d'être
permanent et c'est ce qui est moins
viable à long terme
et là vous avez justement étudié
l'option dorée du
ir progressivement les prestations de la
pcu un peu comme l'assurance emploi
finalement ça fonctionnerait comment si
on faisait cela c'est à la demande du
député dan houser de la colombie
britannique qui fait partie du caucus
conservateur qui nous a demandé
d'étudier le coût de ces paramètres là
et en vertu de ce qui nous a demandé il
nous a demandé d'étudier le coût d'un
programme où les gens pourraient gagner
plus de 1000 $ et être toujours éligible
à la piscine mais les revenus gagnés au
delà de 1000 $ réduire l apc à un rythme
de 50 cents par dollar gagné ce qui
ferait en sorte que à une paix si de
2000 $ par mois les gens seraient
éligibles jusqu'à ce qu'ils gagnent
environ 5000 dollars par watt
ça rendrait pizza éligibles à la pcu ce
que ça augmenterait aussi son coup
malheureusement quel serait donc les
avantages de réduire progressivement le
pc ou est-ce que vous pensez que ça
pourrait avoir une incitation positive
sur le retour au travail paie c'est un
des gros avantages d'une paix su comme
celle-là c'est à dire que les gens
présentement font face à un dilemme
ben ce qui n'est pas vraiment un dilemme
les gens qui gagnent 1000 dollars ou
moins par mois sont éligibles à la
piscine mais aussitôt qu'ils gagnent
plus de 1000 $ ils font face à un mur où
ils sont inéligibles à 2000 $ de pays
dont quelques choix de gagner 995 $ ou
1100 $ le choix est facile parce que en
augmentant son revenu de très peu hyper
2000 $ par mois
alors qu'avec la proposition
conservatrice cette personne-là pourrait
quand même accepter de travailler plus
d'heures et recevoir quand même un
montant qui est presque la totalité de
la pcu la réduction serait seulement de
50 % des 100 dollars additionnels dont
les instits ifo travail sont quand même
beaucoup plus grand que avec la pcu
actuelle mais le désavantage c'est que
plus de gens sont éligibles donc tout se
regarde entre 1000 et 5000 dollars ce
qui fait que le coût total du programme
est plus élevé est ce que dans votre
observation des choses on eu besoin de
prolonger la piscine
ça c'est une question très délicate ça
dépend beaucoup du point de vue qu'on
adopte la pythie eu plus généreuse que
l'assurance emploi c'est très nécessaire
pour les gens qui ne se sont toujours
pas retrouvé d'emploi et on peut penser
facilement au restaurant ou au bord ou à
l'ensemble l'industrie touristique
cependant si on est dans certains
secteurs où il ya encore des pénuries de
main d'oeuvre on peut penser que
l'abolition de la pcu ou son expiration
tel que prévu faciliterait le
recrutement pour certains employeurs
donc c'est une décision éminemment
politique dans laquelle je ne
m'aventurerais heureusement pas si on
faisait cela prolonger la pcu comme
comme il est proposé ici jusqu'en
janvier prochain le déficit budgétaire
de m'élever 21e dépasserait donc les 300
milliards de dollars
c'est fort probable que le déficit
dépasserait les 300 milliards de dollars
on le saura évidemment un peu plus on
aura plus de détails là dessus au fur et
à mesure que les données économiques
ediciones rentrer par exemple la semaine
dernière on a vu des rapports sur le
marché du travail
l enquête sur la population active qui
suggère une reprise de l'emploi donc
c'est un peu plus rapide que ce qu'on
prévoyait il ya quelques semaines
donc c'est possible que l'économie
reprenne plus vite que prévu ce qui
réduirait un peu le déficit mais avec
une prolongation de la piscine et un
enrichissement comme celui là c'est
évident que le déficit fédéral serait
beaucoup plus élevé que kitty seraient
en l'absence de cette prolongation
faut-il un budget 2020 21 ou à tout le
moins une mise à jour budgétaire
économique prochaine
ottawa cheval prochaine prochains jours
prochaines semaines d'ici la fin du mois
d'août selon moi oui à les budgets et
les mises à jour économique sont à une
excellente façon pour les canadiens de
connaître l'état des finances publiques
non seulement l'état des finances
publiques mais aussi l'état de
l'économie et aussi les plans du
gouvernement concernant les dépenses
publiques et la direction qu'il désire
prendre au cours des prochains mois est
présentement en l'absence d'un budget ou
d'une mise à jour économique et
financière
on a absolument aucune des
du plan du gouvernement fédéral pour la
suite des choses on a une bonne idée de
l'état des finances publiques parce que
mon but mon bureau a publié des rapports
assez régulier et le gouvernement publie
les coûts des mesures mais ça donne un
portrait du passé ça donne aucune
indication de ce que le gouvernement
prévoit faire au cours des prochains
mois mais gouvernement dit il trop
d'incertitudes
quelle serait la valeur d'un budget ou
d'une mise à jour avec autant
d'incertitudes dans dans l'économie
présentement c'est vrai que beaucoup
d'incertitudes mais l'incertitude bien
au toujours dans la mesure où par
exemple en 2016 lorsque le gouvernement
fédéral a déposé son budget personne
n'aurait pu prévoir l'élection d'octobre
aux états unis ce qui est un élément
d'incertitude important on l'a vu quand
la suite sur le commerce international
notamment dont il toujours des éléments
d'incertitude mais parce que on n'est
pas certains des chiffres qu'on
publierait dans une mise à jour
économique se veut pas dire qu'on doit
éviter d'en faire une
des chiffres qui sont avec un niveau
d'incertitude plus élevé que la normale
sont toujours mieux et que l'absence
complète de direction ce qu'on a
présentement on a absolument rien de la
part du gouvernement
merci beaucoup pour cette cette analyse
monsieur giraud ce soir